Attention, gorehounds: 2019 was a year that
brought us plenty of sinister thrillers and
chillers, so we thought we'd point out a few
creepshows that really demand your attention.
Get ready to scream your heart out, because
these are the most disturbing movies of 2019.
It's easy to forget now, but just a few short
years ago, no one really knew who Robert Eggers
was.
That changed overnight in 2016 upon the release
of the nerve-shattering Gothic folktale The
Witch, a film that comes highly recommended
for fans of arthouse horror.
After The Witch, fans were eager to see what
Eggers would conjure up next, including actors
Willem Dafoe and Robert Pattinson.
In fact, they both reportedly reached out
to Eggers and expressed interest in jumping
on his next project, whatever that might be.
Perhaps they regretted the decision upon arriving
on the set of The Lighthouse, as the film's
icy shoot in Nova Scotia was reportedly a
challenging one.
And make no mistake: The Lighthouse is an
extremely challenging film.
"I'm damn well wedded to this 'ere light."
We'll keep our lips sealed on all the major
twists and turns of the plot, because the
less you know going in, the better.
We will say that this is a story about a pair
of lighthouse keepers who are doing whatever
they can to stay sane on an increasingly mystifying
New England island in the 1890s.
Eggers' latest is undoubtedly one of the weirdest
films of 2019.
It may also be one of the best.
Todd Phillips' dark, stylish Joker finally
gives everyone's favorite supervillain an
origin story, and a highly disturbing one
at that.
In a standout performance that's already drawing
award nominations, Joaquin Phoenix plays Arthur
Fleck, a social outcast who suffers from narcissistic
delusions.
All too soon, those delusions give way to
horrific bursts of violence.
The film is arguably even darker than any
installment of Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy, calling to mind gritty Martin Scorsese
classics like Taxi Driver and The King of
Comedy.
There's no arguing that Phillips' tale of
a deranged stand-up comic is hopelessly bleak…and
critics spilled gallons of ink writing about
the film's excessive violence.
But perhaps the most disturbing aspect of
Joker is how it succeeds in holding up a funhouse
mirror to our own troubled times.
Beneath all the greasepaint, the story of
Arthur Fleck is one you wouldn't be surprised
to see on the evening news.
It's a timely cautionary tale, and it hits
hard.
In the summer of 2018, Ari Aster unleashed
the unholy horror film Hereditary upon unsuspecting
audiences.
And in the summer of 2019, he delivered his
latest experiment in terror.
The fact that Midsommar is mostly set in broad
daylight certainly doesn't detract from the
horror.
In fact, in several key scenes, it is the
According to Aster, Midsommar is just a small
film about an unhealthy relationship that
goes up in flames.
And that's an apt description, at least on
paper.
The doomed couple in question visits a Swedish
village's mid-summer festival.Their adventure
eventually turns into a full-fledged waking
nightmare that gives The Wicker Man a run
for its money.
Soon enough, they find themselves hopelessly
adrift in the darkest margins of the occult.
We'll go ahead and say it: This is folk horror
at its most folked-up.
"What is it?"
"It has special properties."
"What am I going through?"
Of course, Midsommar is a "breakup movie"
only in the way that Hereditary is a "family
drama," and rest assured, every evil under
the sun is on full display here.
If you've yet to see the film, you should
know that it's often unbearably gory.
Brace yourself for plenty of shocking sights
that you simply can't unsee, popcorn not included.
This just might be the scariest, most hallucinatory
film of the year.
Consider yourself warned.
With Depraved, underground filmmaker Larry
Fessenden gives us a modern-day retelling
of the Frankenstein story.
The plot is a very familar one: A demented
doctor cobbles together several stray body
parts to give life to an undead something-or-other.
Rest assured, this film is fueled by enough
blood and gore to satisfy even the most discerning
horror fan, but thanks to deeply human characters
and an inventive and insightful script, Depraved
is far more nuanced and affecting than you
might expect.
"In my dreams I'm someone else."
"I owe you something like a normal life."
In this impressively twisted film, even the
noblest intentions can be corrupted…and
men and monsters are often one in the same.
One part monster movie, one part character
drama, Depraved explores heavy themes like
post-war trauma and mental illness…but it
remains first and foremost a horror story.
A really messed-up one.
Two years have passed since Andy Muschietti
unleashed It: Chapter One on an unsuspecting
public.
The film certainly succeeded in scaring the
bejeezus out audiences.
It also scared up almost $700 million worldwide
at the box office.
Suffice to say, expectations were high for
Chapter Two of this monstrously frightening
clown epic.
And we're here to tell you that, yes, It:
Chapter Two is every bit as unsettling as
its predecessor.
Bill Skarsgård's absolutely mental take on
Pennywise is still very much the star of the
show, though he's got some stiff competition
thanks to Bill Hader and Jessica Chastain,
both of whom turn in powerhouse performances.
It: Chapter Two definitely delivers the unbridled
terror that you so desperately crave, and
it amps up the emotional stakes at every turn,
leading to quite a gut-punch of an ending.
"For twenty-seven years, I craved you.
I missed you."
It's that rare sort of horror film that aims
to shock you and pull at your heartstrings,
and it succeeds brilliantly.
Set in Paris in the summer of '79, Yann Gonzalez's
Knife + Heart tells the story of Anne, a filmmaker
who specializes in arty adult films of the
all-male persuasion.
But just as Anne begins her most ambitious
film to date, the members of her troupe start
getting killed off one by one.
She suddenly finds herself smack dab in the
middle of a twisted, heartbreaking mystery
that effectively turns her whole world upside-down.
Gonzalez delivers a LGBTQ-centric, truly unique
slasher that pulls no punches.
It's certainly not for the squeamish, but
adventurous horror fans will definitely want
to take a look.
Wounds tells the story of a cocksure French
Quarter bartender named Will, played by Armie
Hammer.
After he takes home a phone that was left
at his bar, his life begins to get a whole
lot weirder.
And when he starts texting the stranger on
the other end, and exploring the highly unsettling
contents of the phone itself, things take
a turn for the truly terrifying.
As Will and his girlfriend Carrie, played
by Dakota Johnson, start to unravel the mystery
behind the mysterious smartphone, the film
plunges us deeper into a devilish and depraved
narrative that owes as much to David Cronenberg
as it does to H.P.
Lovecraft.
And we don't make those comparisons lightly.
"There was a ritual."
Based on a bizarre and macabre true story,
Lords of Chaos revolves around a seriously
troubled Norwegian teen who called himself
Euronymous and created what he called "true
Norwegian black metal" with his band Mayhem.
In attempting to bring Mayhem to the masses,
Euronymous and his pals engaged in a wave
of shocking publicity stunts that shook Norway
to its very core.
Mayhem's live shows soon became the place
to see severed pigs' heads, fire-breathing
maniacs, and bloody acts of self-mutilation.
As Euronymous and his crew continue to push
one another, the lines between "act" and "reality"
dissolve, paving the way for arson, violence,
and death.
Lords of Chaos tells a story that feels way
too strange to be true, but it's entirely
based in fact.
For his part, director Jonas Åkerlund allows
the increasingly grisly tale to speak for
itself, and he seems to take no particular
delight in presenting the most shocking aspects
of the case at hand.
Ultimately, this is haunting biographical
drama about artistic ambition run amok.
Add Joe Begos' beastly flick Bliss to the
list of vampire tales reclaiming the genre's
menacing grandeur— even if the word "vampire"
is never actually uttered in the film.
Set among the venomous vistas of modern-day
Los Angeles, Bliss finds a tragically self-centered
painter stuck in a maddening creative block,
and in debt to some serious shakers in the
superficial L.A. art world.
In desperate need of inspiration, she turns
to a powerful hallucinatory drug, and with
a little help from a soulless gal-pal, she
quickly spirals into a blood-soaked nightmare
of lust, death, and, yes, creation.
"I don't know, something came over me.
And it all just started pouring out of me.
I don't even remember doing it."
The results are spellbindingly sick and twisted,
and unbelievably gory to boot.
Set in Mexico amid the turmoil of the country's
violent drug wars, Issa López's pitch-black
fantasy Tigers Are Not Afraid tells the story
of a little girl named Estrella, whose mother
has mysteriously disappeared.
One day, to soothe Estrella after gunfire
is heard outside her classroom, a teacher
gives her three pieces of chalk and says that
they can magically grant her three wishes.
Accompanied by a band of fellow orphans, Estrella
adjusts to the perpetual dangers of her new
life and comes to realize that those three
wishes may actually be real.
Of course, wishes rarely come true in the
way you expect.
The film is a pitch-perfect, relentlessly
bleak chiller that's as insightful as it is
creepy.
Edgy, emotional, and deeply moving,Tigers
Are Not Afraid will linger in your head long
after the credits roll.
Some people might not even consider Amanda
Kramer's Ladyworld a movie at all.
It's more of an experimental mood piece about
the fragility of human nature and social structures.
After being cut off from the world in the
wake of an unknown natural disaster, a group
of teenage girls are going positively mad.
The film borrows heavily from William Golding's
1954 novel Lord of the Flies, essentially
moving the plot from an isolated island paradise
to the suffocating confines of an apartment.
Rest assured, you can look forward to plenty
of backstabbing and torture, both of the emotional
and physical variety.
"You are a bad leader, and we were never friends."
The claustrophobic photography and wildly
offbeat sound design is bound to keep viewers
very much on edge.
Featuring a stellar ensemble cast, this film
is definitely its own beast, and that beast
has one hell of a bite.
It's safe to say that Zach Lipovsky and Adam
B. Stein's outrageous sci-fi film Freaks is
unlike anything you've ever seen before.
And take our word for it: This film has plenty
of surprises in store for you, so do your
best to avoid any spoilers before giving it
a look.
Think you already have a good sense of what
Freaks is all about because you watched the
trailer?
Think again.
Freaks is the story of a bold little girl,
played by newcomer Lexy Kolker, who's been
raised in captivity by her overprotective
father, played by Emile Hirsch.
When she tries to make a break for it, she
soon discovers that the world isn't at all
what she thought it was.
In fact, it might be a far more dangerous
place than she ever could've imagined.
"You could buy any flavor you wanted with
that."
"Really?"
"Yeah, come around back.
Come inside.
Taste any flavor you want."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.